[Music]
he got down on one knee before he got
flattened by security video of a man
getting tackled while proposing at an LA
Dodgers game is uniting both fans of
love and awesome beautiful violence
watch
[Music]
thank you
it's weird those two guys actually ran
off together that happened during last
week's home opener where the young man
stood out from the players since he
wasn't on steroids
of course running onto the field is not
allowed and it offers one of the only
instances where someone can beat the
out of you and not get arrested
it's amazing it's a free punch literally
cops can't even do that to escaping
felons
think about it and so Stadium security
reacted with a tackle that was so
physical afterward the guard lit up a
cigarette
[Laughter]
the craziest part is the proposal
actually worked the woman said yes
writing on her Instagram quote okay the
best proposal ever I love you and yes
I'll marry you they plan to exchange
vows in the middle of a WNBA game where
they'll have some privacy
foreign
but frankly that guy got off easy only
getting tackled the last time I saw a
public proposal I hate them I hate them
this is how I handled it
honey I love you so much I just have one
question
will you marry me yes
yeah
[Applause]
normally
I'm against the droning of American
citizens except for that
Harold if you were the woman's father
and she called you let's say it's one of
your daughters calls you and says you
know Simon or whatever this guy's name
is what do you what would you say would
you say oh I like that this is going to
be a great son-in-law or run screaming
from him
well I think somebody I know in admire
and respect said a little earlier that
one thing two things that happened one
this is what the divorce lawyers for
both sides are going to see is the
predicate for the divorce when it
happens and two it should be about the
the the person you're proposing to I'm
not sure she wanted this if she did want
this she won the baseball game where her
husband broke
jumped over a fence ran into Midfield
and and did this and she would be happy
with it but I probably would not advise
young Georgia Ford's fiance that's my
daughter's name nine and I hope I hope
she never gets married baby you can
always live at home if that's what you
want to do but I would not advise her
fiance to do to do this one back I tell
you that dude looked like he enjoyed
tackling him that's the thing it's a
weird thing it is a free punch this is a
situation where are there any rules like
if I mean like you could literally shoot
like tackle to kill like that's a look
at that he loved every minute of that
look at that never warned him never saw
him coming yeah and then he had to go to
jail and then so she had to go get him
from jail the guy that got tackled him
yeah like don't give me an errand well
here
I mean Chad
you know like you like oh we're we're
engaged and the first thing I have to do
is go get your ass from jail I know what
is that what is that portend is that the
way you use that one I'm not doing
errands of any kind yeah
so I I think that's that's the wrong way
to set it up yeah do you know anybody
that has long marriages after dramatic
proposals I don't think they exist
I I those people are not in my life
anymore yeah right the Gutfeld Institute
of matrimony according to our statistics
none of them survive none of them Joe uh
you're single still right no one's
gotten their talent into me yet
I can't they can't tame you you're a
wild man right it's like trying to ride
a rodeo Bronco yeah
on top
[Applause]
that is so disgusting
when you want bestiality jokes you come
to this show
don't go to outnumbered you'll be sorely
disappointed
your thoughts your thoughts on this well
first I I think that was security guard
brutality yeah but I think you know
maybe the security guard's excuses he
really hates weddings yeah the other
thing is like I I hate hate these public
displays of of affection for attention
yeah like I'm tired it's just it's the
best time ever to be a narcissist like
you know Father's Day is coming up and
people are going to write like Happy
Father's Day to my dad on Instagram and
their dad's not even on Instagram you
know and it's like what what am I
supposed what am I supposed to do with
that they're like oh she said Happy
Father's Day to her dad on father that
that makes sense
it's true it's true it's it maybe that's
the original virtue signaling you know
Molly the the defense of this very
violent tackle is to dissuade people
from Ever doing it again but then you
see the um the amount of exposure this
guy gets and I bet you there'll be a
bunch of copycats people running on to
like you know other sports uh but you
know not well unlike you cynical and
unromantic people I hope there are more
things like this like at least someone's
asking someone to get married I mean we
have nobody doing that these days like
Civilization is collapsing I'm I'm not
like a huge fan of the public thing but
it's better than not asking anyone
that's very that's a record reflect I
fully agree with Molly
well said it is interesting though I
said I think I mentioned this on the
five I can't remember I tried to block
it out of my head
but there is you can't trust people that
are uh that are uh that are
um uh victim to their own by their own
chemical changes like that's a guy
that's like so he's about the love he's
not about the person right that goes
away like in a couple of years you don't
even it's gone
[Music]
get used to it
yeah
I agree with Molly
I mean maybe maybe he'll just up the
ante every anniversary or maybe it's
just a fun thing that they can remember
and tell their kids and grandkids about
oh that's sweet no no you're probably
wrong but
there's no way that that wedding is beer
and wine only though yeah
excellent points
yeah gonna be some looking
bridesmaids there huh what do you say
what am I talking about that was all you
that's all me yeah hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else